This video is about free
money. Say whoa. Hello world.
It's the Raj and universal basic income.
It's a centuries old idea that we might
just be able to implement on a global
scale using recent advances
in blockchain technology.
I'll give a technical overview of some
projects in the space aiming to do that.
In this video,
we are increasingly moving towards an
age of abundance where AI is accelerating
progress in almost every field.
Ai agents can do jobs that humans would
normally do with far more efficiency
diagnostic apps or replacing
thousands of healthcare workers,
self driving cars and trucks
will replace 5 million drivers.
Internet sales are on the way to
replacing millions of retail workers.
It's happening staggeringly fast and
it's not just AI that tricking the job
markets.
It's the way we've structured the web
currently of BW services collect and
monetize the majority of the world's data.
As AI takes on more and more labor,
the data you generate,
your unique perspective of the world,
that's something that
no robot can ever take,
but right now we're giving it away
for free in return for a free service.
So the few who run these massive
services are earning all the money.
Wealth inequality continues
to rise because of this.
And a recent study shows that almost
half of all jobs in the U S or at risk of
being automated in the next 20 years.
So what do we do here? Well, we, well,
we can't just stop working on technology.
It's too useful and humanity needs it
to solve some of the world's biggest
problems.
What if people could earn a set amount
of money every month just because they
exist? This idea is called
a universal basic income.
The most common proposal for how a system
like this would work is one where a
national government sends out regular
checks to every citizen regardless of
their employment status.
Pilots of this style of program are
already underway in Finland and Canada.
In rural Kenya, a basic income
is managed by give directly,
even in India with a population
of over 1 billion people.
It's considering establishing a basic
income in the u s y Combinator started a
basic income test last year on a
small portion of the local population.
And for decades,
residents of Alaska have each received
about two k US dollars every year from
the Alaska permanent fund.
So the idea has been tested and we've
seen the results instead of people just
becoming lazy and unproductive.
Studies show that it actually increased
people's productivity rather than
reducing it.
That's because it both improved their
mental and physical health and encourage
them to pursue work that
actually mattered to them,
not just to put bread on the table.
And when you actually care about
the work that you're doing,
your output is going to far exceed
what you do if you didn't care.
You could imagine though that this would
take a long time for countries to adopt
and the need for this is
really on a global scale.
Since automation technology affects
everybody who can access the Internet and
allowing a few people to decide how much
money is given to a very large amount
of people. Has the potential for
corruption? Is there a better way?
Well,
we know that bitcoin's blockchain for
the first time allowed the minting and
distribution of money to be decentralized.
That is decided by rules encoded into
a network protocol instead of behind
closed doors,
and it did this on a global scale.
It created this global network of
miners and developers and users.
Could we create some kind
of cryptocurrency system
that we could dedicate to
distributing a basic income? It would be
pretty cool. It'd be globally accessible,
open source and a much faster solution
than relying on national governments,
but we have two major questions to
answer if we're to get there. First,
where does this money come from?
And second,
how do we prove that one
person only has one account?
We don't want to make it easy for one
person to create multiple accounts and
received multiple basic income streams.
Let's take a look at two projects in
this space to see how they're doing it.
The first is grant coin,
which is a fork of pure coin.
The founders of this cryptocurrency
created a nonprofit organization based in
the US.
It's already distributed the equivalent
of about 13,000 US dollars to more than
1500 participants in over a 79 countries
across the world for fruit to verify
the identity of its users.
It asks them to upload a
government issued photo id.
Although this is a centralized
identity system, it works the grant,
quite foundation staff and volunteers
manually review these applications to
ensure that each id is in fact unique.
The founders gave 99% of all created grand
coin to the foundation which it holds
in reserve.
The remaining 1% is created through the
proof of work mining process to reward
minors for maintaining the public ledger.
The plan is to gradually release the
coin into circulation during the next 50
years. The foundation acts
as a hub for donations.
These donations can be from charity
groups, other Ngos and individual donors.
Generally,
as is the case with most cryptocurrencies,
the more people that get involved,
the more people want to join and this
rise in interest is what causes people to
want to trade that currency for
another which has more value.
As far as I can tell.
This is currently the most successful
implementation of a crypto basic income.
Another cool project is called circles.
They're idea is that every person in
the system gets their own currency,
but this currency has no value at first.
People who know each other can agree to
set a fixed exchange rate between their
currencies. They would mutually
agree to each other's existence.
They formed a circle of two people and
within this circle both currencies can be
seen as equal.
This allows exchanges along circles
and connects people across a network
together also considered
a web of trust model.
So if person a has a relationship with B
and B has a relationship with see a can
pay c with c coined by exchanging a
coins for be coins and be bitcoins to see
coins, it's built on top
of the theory blockchain.
Each account constantly generates an
income of about a thousand units per week
and the rate at which the
income is generated increases
by about 5% every year.
Groups can also be created.
These groups can verify new accounts as
members and exclude certain accounts as
well. Members can even convert their
private money into group money.
This one seems complicated,
but hey,
the founders have the right intentions
and the get hub repository is active.
There are some other examples as well,
and I've linked to them
in the video description.
Pretty much all of these
are very new pilots.
No one has really figured out a
massively scalable way to do this yet,
but all the building blocks are there.
So to summarize,
automation is going to replace a lot of
humans in doing a mundane work over the
coming years.
We can use blockchain technology to
experiment with creating systems that
provide a universal basic income to
people globally and to projects that are
working on this. Currently,
our grants, coin and circles.
The coding challenge for this week is
to create your own plan for how a basic
income crypto currency system would work.
Submit your get hub links
in the comment section,
and I'll announce the top
two entries next Friday.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos.
And for now I've got to save the world,
so thanks for watching.